[Musik]
s
jetzt was bist jetzt überleen was meine
bin ich beobacht sie sind sehr sehr
unruhig Gefühl jeden grü oder den sich
[Applaus]
samm richtig das z
dann bin am überlegen es ist das ABG
getreidefal und das ist einf sehr sehr
lut
zumchliche du immer noch Adrenalin
Situation oder ist das schon lang ja
jetzt schnell ein Moment 1 2 3 4
5 14 15 16 17 18
St
probiermzpirsche ein halbes Jahr
begleite ich Fabian Kern er ist
Wildhüter der Stadt Zürich ich selber
bin in der Ausbildung zum Jäger und
möchte wissen was genau macht ein
Wildhüter die Schlange im Keller der
Dachs im Vorgarten und Vögel auf der
Baustelle das alles werde ich mit
wildhüte Kern erleben aber der Rei
noch
[Musik]
rund ein Viertel der Stadt Zürich ist
Walt diese Waldfläche gilt aus
wildschongebiet für Rehe Hirsche und
sogar Gemsen das Jagen ist hier Aufgabe
der Wildhüter privates jagen ist nicht
erlaubt Wildhüter überprüfen die
Population und greifen wenn nötig ein
ich treffe Fabian Kern früh morgens im
Stadtwald
wir sind auf der rejagd wir haben jedes
Jahr bestimmt jzah re W
bestand und im Moment sind schmalre das
sind wiriche letzte Jahr wo kein Junge
Hand und Böck zu jagof und da im
Wald V
dreb und da geb
weiß ich hat letzt Jahr regeis 2
männliche Kit da W ich gerne eine V de
zwei ich gern
erlecke wie viel men die
erleck mir Vorgaben über von der Fischer
jagdverwaltig vom Kanton und das bewegt
sich immer so zwischen 120 und 160 180
im Ganzes
stockgebt
im Dickicht ersperrt wildhüte Kern mit
dem Nachtsichtgerät zwei
re doch wir waren wohl zu laut das re
schreckt wie es in der Fachsprache
heißt das ist die Re und mit mit dem
Schreck die andere
war
dann zeigt sich ein rebok der könnte
passen das ist ein Reb vom letzte Jahr
das W eigentlich guter Abgang aber er st
auf privatareal
wo das heißt privat Grundstück darf du
nicht Jaen in Notfall darf privat
Grundstück also
zumrank lös aber da ich schon mit de
lienscha Besitzer und er möchte das
nicht und das ist sch respektieren und
zu dem ist ein wunderschönne Flack
Austritt
wo mus nicht nur im Wald in
St und das seinen
gegönnt dir den
Job ja was soll ich sagen B
vorstellen was ist der Teil vom Job die
am wenigstf müste
wer ja so komisch wie dönt manm manmals
jag
selber da hat sich viel verändert s s
ich das brflich mache es ist es F nicht
immer gich
L
Fabian Kern gibt mir ein Zeichen stehen
zu
bleiben bei einem Schuss will er nicht
gefilmt werden das sei aus Respekt dem
Tier
gegenüber mir wet jetzt im Moment und
gön der gen mit den
anführ aber es müsste eigentlich alles
gut
se hat man da schlecht gsse Nein
schlecht gewssse nicht
aber herüber la und tot und ich glaube
wenn wenn einem das wenn einem das
emotional gar nicht wird
berühreen dann wären wir am falschen Ort
dann ist man am falschen Ort als Jäger
also es es muss schon es muss es muss
Sinn Sinnhaftigkeit
hab wo man sich auch nicht nur i also wo
man wirklich weiß mal das macht
verhaltensbiologisch Sinn ich ersetze
das großraubbtier was jetzt da im stadtw
zür
GT re hat bewegigsradius v 3 400 m und
da merkt man sofort W WN dann D groß
wird es GT Kranke geh wo wo auf Straße
ret alsobi man könnte jetzt schon sagen
das ist perfekt so K wie z oder
ja also aufgrund von D was ich da was
ich da
zeigt das re ist nur noch zambrochen und
das hat nicht mal der Schuss
gehört eigentlich so W ich es mir
wünsche und W ich es mir das Tier
wünsche dass
dass miniarbeit genau die Perfektion
zeigt sobald zum Leben und Tod
geht das muss manriben und und wenn ein
klingt das dann so könen umszen dann
dann ist wirklich das erreicht wo wo wo
aus macht ich das ti bit
deponieren dass es nicht ganz so Straß
Lied und
dann GN nicht Auto holen und
dann aufladen und könt das Gogo wieder
verarbeiten und das machen wir das das
mach du
das aufade
irgendwie gen
genau diese Maßnahme ist nötig weil im
Stadtwald viele Menschen unterwegs
sind Fabian Kern erzählt mir dass er
immer wieder beschimpft und bedroht wird
dieser Passant hier ist dem Wildhüter
allerdings
wohlgesonnen vor W das ist schön das ist
sehr schön danke vi schön
Wochen ist das das Alltag
od anders also es geht natürlich beides
aber es gibt schon viel l wo wo schätz
was mir da n ich als wildte mir als
Stadt sü was mir
dafür ja für für le schaff und es gibt
auch andere wo vielleicht aus mangel
verständnisen Situationen falschätz min
Tätigkeit wo exponiert ist mit dem und
und und der Buckel wo wo nicht immer
verstanden wird aber da wird
mit mit aufklärsarbeit mit Gespräche
kann man da viel erreichen und dann gibt
die mus gar nichtar ke Zang überkto dann
einfach nur der Fokus auf Waffen oder du
stierö
Hand aber die sind mit Respekt
behand ja gerade weil er so exponiert
ist hält sich der Wildhüter und
expolizist zurück was sein Privatleben
anbelangt laut Lebensmittelgesetz muss
er das re innerhalb von 90 Minuten
verarbeiten
aber es gibt genügend Zeit für ein
wichtiges
Ritual warum machst
das T Teil von M Rudel ich B Chef und
machen Beute und das hilft bit zum das
zum die
bezirkü undichtig S sich ich
nichtzu auf Wild duf könt und nach ist
schon gut el Schine Hop Stiege
so der rebur wird auf das Areal der
Grünstadt Züg
gebracht hier kann der wildhüte das Tier
verarbeiten und
untersuchen
zu nur wild ja Fabian K erhält das
Wildfleisch aber nicht umsonst das re
ist Eigentum der
Stadt
h Schuss
aber
lsch zum
beurteil und das dar jetzt so schön
abgranzt gen die verschiedene far das
tieris
bedanklos Konsum bringen jedem Tier W
lemittelproduktion
wildmarke das garantiert
Rückverfolgbarkeit
Rest
FA anschließend geht das in den
Kühlschrank und wartet auf einen
Abnehmer in diesem Fall WD es seem
Metzger
verkauft nebenan befindet sich Kerns
Büro alle Angaben über den geschossenen
rebock muss er festhalten Büroarbeit und
Sitzungen auch das sind Aufgaben eines
stadtwildhüters immer mit dabei die
Hunde Dixi und elelfer da wildhüte immer
wieder verletzte Tiere aufsuchen müssen
ist der Besitz eines ausgebildeten
Jagdhundes eine
[Musik]
Voraussetzung trst du auch den Auslauf
ja also ich will lügen wenn ich sagen es
es ist für mich nicht schön schwer
zwischen
zwei7igeus glaub h cake entdeckt el komm
so ist fein ja so ist
[Musik]
fein nein nein
fertig fertig
fertig
[Applaus]
so macht sit
Sitz
[Musik]
gut ohne
Leine
el so jetzt Hund
[Musik]
abtragen meldet mögliche wildsauschäden
in seinem Haferfeld Fabian muss
ausrücken ist schwierig
ze als Grund vom schatbild ist es gut
möglich ja ganz frisch macht mir auch
nichtruck und schmeckt nicht schmeckt
nicht V Wildau da wie
schmckauau das ist so
es GT so der verglich schmck wie die wür
Wildschweine vermehren sich rasanter als
z.B R und können erhebliche Schäden in
der Landwirtschaft verursachen zur
Aufgabe der wildhüte gehört es die
Population zu kontrollieren viicht wo in
G und dann je nach
D
da V jung Schü das ist dann so ein
verkrämigsabschuss das merkt sich dann
die bche merkt euch geförlich und führt
dann ih ihre irer oder ihre Jungen im da
das Jagen ist nur ein Teil seine Aufgabe
aus Wildhüter meist vermittelt er
zwischen Wildtieren und Menschen ich hab
das Telefon über von me Bürger in
zürwitika und der mir Gag Schlangen im
Schacht nicht alltägliche Arbeit und
gehört eigentlich jetzt nicht Kern
Kompetenz wildhürter aber es ist wilder
ich weiß dass
wi r hat und drum probieren wir jetzt
einit schange wie
husbewohner n jetzt spezialusrü ir ich
sicher t mal mit und taslamp und dann
mal
ich überhaupt gesehen und und und was
sie dann Brae am Samstag bin
ichaufen und der Nachbar hat
R und ich bin
Bar wie lang ist sie wenn sie jetzt mü
ich w zwischen 50 und 50 g
sicher
ne also ne GT nicht also
sch
das verstorben
Geliebten
aber mit de große mitich natürlich
irgendwo
muss vorsichtig
W Verm die
so sind fress also die fress fr vor
allem und ganz scharf und S nicht schlü
dass sie dass sie das sind ke Gift aber
andere und auch Respekt sie so eine drü
wo so ganzes übel übel stinken Sekret
schid und das wir
eigentlich nicht unbedingt auf meine
Kleider und
me mit dem eltis das bringt
weg ich tu mal noch schnelles Telefon
machen Telefon ich LCH Telefon bringen
da mit mit dem Handy ja
super nicht und Telefon got und mit der
Hand hab sie DST Schlange nein okay nein
ja wenn WS
schange
Angst
ganz wenn wenn eckig sind eckig sind
also
kftis den giftig oder nicht giftig
da das
[Gelächter]
ich
kfung der Fabian wildhürterstad zür grü
sie ich habe wieder mal Schlange Thema
ein Lichtschacht ca met50 TF mit so
große Boll
Stei wo man wo man als ich vermut eine
ringelnun hat dem Samstig die verschlüft
sich schoned eine Stei
oder ist das eine ringelnatte das meint
er vorag jetzt B ganz büer ich glaube
die so Ring um der H
glaub nein
das ja also ist die kann ich schon
umbiegen die Stei zum sie suchen oder ja
ne das gut also du nicht das da sag
prima danke viel mal Danke tschüss Ciao
also ist der
reptilipzialist der
kantonspolizi und mir gagt nicht über
also wenn da Steeg die verschlüft sich
immer meh tut sich immer genau genau s
das holzbr
stell ma
genau ja die sind schon schützenswert
und W dass es das oder der Wildhüter so
habe ich den Eindruck hilft den Menschen
nicht nur bei ungebetenen Tieren sondern
er ist auch eine willkommene Abwechslung
in ihrem
Alltag eine Baustelle in Zürich Nord die
baauleitung hat bei der Sanierung eines
dachstockes vogelgezwitcher vernommen
die Vögel beim Brüten zu stören ist
gemäß Jagdgesetz verboten es drohen
Bußen bis zu 10000
Franken
[Musik]
krass
se ja hat unzählige
waschpinaster sind wirklich
unzeilige du h nicht so was nein ich bin
sogar
allergisch jetzt
gehört eigentlich lang Sch
so gehört hat ja der Teil von der
Baustelle kann jetzt noch nicht fre mit
gutem offenbar geht es hier um einen
Hausrotschwanz die Sanierung muss
verschoben werden bis die Vögel
ausgeflogen sind ja zwei Woche da
baustoppp machen W Vogel wie ist das für
e als
baufirmer Sache
wo normaler
dass ein bupolizist kommt und me der
Sicherheit von Mitarbeiter und vonabig
ist aber wenn jetzt Hal so B für mich
auch z mal so dass ich wildhörter mir
baustopf sind Sachen wo mir auch
berücksichtigen und für das jetzt ges
alles klar schönen Tag tschüss danke in
den letzten Jahren hat sich vor allem
eine Tierart immer mehr Zugang in die
Stadtgärten verschafft ein Tier das
Wildhüter Kern gerne mag ich hab im
Winter m über von lichafverwalt wo
großes Loch im Garten entdeckt
hat und die wissen was es ist ich hat
wildtierkera postiert und hab mehrfach
ein Dach draf und ganz viel
Katze jetzt der B überwachen bis man
sicher sind dass ke sind und dann kan
dieenschaft verwaltig
gartenbauunternahmen beftragen zum der
Bau wieder verschlü aber der Winter ist
schlechte zit umum das nchwies dass der
B leer ist will will der Dach macht ja
Winterruhe das heißt Kanal Sie dass paag
drin ist und und nicht
und zum jetzt wirklich ganz sicher s mer
noch mal neu Batterien Kamera und D der
Bau noch paar Tage überwachen
was hab wir denn bei uns im Garten da
Dach und
jetzt ich g nicht DAV dass es Jungtier
da hat zum sicher Sie dass der ist bevor
man der wieder
verschlü
[Musik]
Stör hier stört der da mE
im et und ein Standort der Universität
Zürich Mensch und Tier kommen sich hier
in die Quere das Natur und
heimatschutzgesetz verbietet
grundsätzlich die Zerstörung eines
daxsbaus gemerkt dass man da be der
großbaustellechluss für
Kanalisation hat W quer über der über
der über der Hang da vorne ziehe wo ein
Ries Dachsbau dachsfuchsbauen ist also
es W durchus möglich der Bau
schon 30 40 Jahr
bestt da wir ein von de Haup Gang V dem
großen
Dachsbau riesen erdeus worden ist und
dalich dass der im Moment auch bewohnt
ist befahre wie mir
sagt vom
dachtieg D das relativ super ist der ist
al so voll in gebruch und
bewohnt die Wildkamera bestätigt Fabian
KNS
Annahme hier wohnt eine ganze daxs
[Musik]
Familie ich finde doch so eine
so eine spezielle Tierart dert da stad
zür wirklich Mitte unter der L das aber
zum Teil jahrelang nicht mitüber er hat
v latil her und V V will her ist so
speziell dass es dass es für
mich ich sage jetzt mal so grundlos oder
der Grund muss richtig gut Sie dass ich
Gang und und den Dach
jaglichle der Wildhüter handelt hier im
Interesse des Dachses der Bau bleibt
eine Kanalisation wird umgeleitet bei
den Wildsauen sieht die Situation ganz
anders aus hier muss er eingreifen wir
treffen uns wieder am hönkeberg fabian
hat mich im Voraus gewohnt dass es eine
lange Nacht werden würde wizaut die
findet zu zu
% in der nachtstattt
und halt im Schutz vor der dunkelhe o
dann
die und mir dann halt auch mit
technische Hilfsmittel überliste bis
jetzt nicht gemt du legst viel Wert auf
jagik und so findest Du nach zel
das ja will es ermöglich e
Kön besser treffe oder vor besser was
ist Fürer wir gehört i miteinand spricht
dass man nicht das Muttertier von der
jungen wegchüß zum
[Musik]
BP
mal von Wildkamera wir steh
eigentlich 120 m wi wo so auf der Kamera
sind mit da jetzt platzieren ja fah vi
noch bchen anders die
Z
Bilder
[Musik]
s
jetzt was B jetzt
überlein beobach sie sind sehr sehr
unruhig Gefül jeden grü oder sich
samm
ich richtig das
Z dann B überle ist das ab getre ist
einfach sehr sehr lut
zumschlichechen h du immer noch
Adrenalin ist so Situation oder ist das
schon langbi ja jetzt vielleicht
nichtade schnell ein Moment 1 2 3 4 5 6
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 Stück aber ich
glaube da WN es gar nicht berührt
dann ja dann muss man sich VI ma die
richti
macht probier
[Musik]
pirche ich folge Fabian K Anweisungen
und versuche leise zu
sein wildzauen sein sehr aufmerksam und
riechen und hören
ausgezeichnet sie steh jetzt wieder ganz
dicht binand und sind wieder weg V
probierf viicht am waldr
in
[Musik]
K s s jetzt ganz ganz einam und sind
frasse unmöglich
Schü
bei einem Schuss muss alles stimmen
unter anderem kann Fabian erst dann
schießen wenn eine Sau alleine
steht etwas scheint die Tiere
aufgeschreckt zu
haben jetzt gilt volle Konzentration und
bewusste
Atmung ich erwarte den Schuss und
erschrecke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
trotzdem
okay sie l
vorne da ist K wildstad
zür
fallurstraßechoss danke viel mal schönen
ab
mer machen oder ma ein hey das ist jetzt
vielleicht Polizist
bin und ich auch musruen irgendwelche
komische Schüsse im Wald in der Nacht
und zum das verhinder und will relativ
h es ist kurz nach Mitternacht auß das
erlegte Tier zum Auto bringt wie der Reb
muss auch die Wildsau zeitnah
verarbeitet
[Musik]
Werdener die Arbeit eines
stadtwildhüters so habe ich miterlebt
ist vielfältig einsam nie fertig und zum
großen Teil
unsichtbar doch für das Zusammenleben
von Mensch und Tier in der Stadt ist er
[Musik]
unverzichtbar